We talked about the when of
adaptive design, specifically,
choosing breakpoints, and
using resource qualifiers, like w600dp.
And we also touched on what we
want to fix at these breakpoints.
Let's now get into the how of
implementing adaptive design on Android.
>> Now the simplest to adapt your UI,
is to create a separate
layout in res/layout-w600dp.
You'll probably end up copying and
pasting a bunch of layout XML code,
because your layouts probably
won't be completely different.
For example, here you can see
the basic layout is a top bar,
with a collection below it, and
it's the same in this tablet layout.
This approach of simply copying and
pasting
will quickly lead to a maintenance
problem with your code, where you'll
need to make the same changes in
lots of different layout XML files.
Now, you could, instead,
just vary your subsection of the layout,
using layout includes.
Layout includes are, basically,
a way of saying, hey, right here,
at this point in my layout, insert
the contents of this other layout.
In this example, the list view
portion of the UI is in an include.
The nice thing is that the container
layout, and the included layout,
can each vary individually,
using resource qualifiers.
So in this code, we're saying, when
the width of the screen ins over 600dp,
change the included layout to this one.
That layout can be better optimized for
tablet's, such as using a grid,
instead of a list.